we are FICA confirm that fan and that's
ficus this is fresh dress fest last I
checked there is only room at Coachella
for one celestial goddess and you sir
are not Rihanna don't try this at home
you end up looking less like a sexy
vegetable and more like a freaky player
goes literal garbage this scholar Alice
is stealing a show that fari throwback
tracksuit really channeling JLo here
making this Queen the hottest Jenny on
the block a must-do ah she looked like a
haunted doll and who did her makeup
Annabelle from the conjuring she liked
the Dutchess of Candy Kingdom with us
gingersnap cookie for a hat 100% please
don't love this David Bowie on vacation
more like Tilda Swinton at home and now
but definitely do not definitely do not
appropriate hopefully quite simple to
stop doing it we hope this helped
enlighten your future trendy selves
dress well and see you at class pipette